the British Prime Minister's personal
battle would covet 19 continues with him
still in intensive care for the first
time in days though some positive news
on Boris Johnson's condition the latest
from the hospital is that the Prime
Minister remains in intensive care where
his condition is improving I can also
tell you that he has been sitting up in
bed and engaging positively with the
clinical team the Prime Minister is not
only my colleague and my boss but also
my friend and my thoughts are with him
and his family the 55 year old tested
positive two weeks ago he was admitted
to hospital on Sunday evening with a
persistent high temperature and cough he
was later moved to a specialist unit
where he's conscious and has received
oxygen scientists say the UK is entering
the deadliest phase of the outbreak in
East London an exhibition centre
converted into a 500 bed hospital in
only nine days has admitted its first
patients in this London hospital medics
are handling a surge in sufferers but
there are worries about the availability
of life-saving equipment we've got
enough people that's difficult but it's
inevitably we've had staff go off we
have currently got enough oxygen our
current problem today is having enough
ITU great time ventilators some of those
admitted are young and fit with no
underlying health problems you don't
know how bad it is until it actually
hits you and so I would absolutely urge
everybody to listen to the government
guidance and stay away from people this
is the hospital where Johnson is under
close observation just across the River
Thames from the houses of parliament the
scene of so many of Johnson's recent
victories only a few weeks ago he was
telling journalists how he was still
shaking hands with people some of them
patients in hospital but that was before
current restrictions before the death
toll started to accelerate and now
Johnson like so many others across the
UK have to put their faith in one thing
modern medicine in his absence Johnson's
designated deputy da man
robbed and the rest of the cabinet are
debating when to lift the lockdown was
costing British businesses billions of
dollars after facing criticism for
failing to impose restrictions quickly
enough there's now a danger of the
government lifting things too soon a
risk known all too well by London's
transport workers 14 have died after
contracting kovat 19 most of them bus
drivers the price of keeping our cities
moving neve barker al jazeera london